The big take away
from this is very interesting.
They are outlining several steps
that many different bodies,
whether it's Congress,
bar associations, within different states
or law enforcement agencies, the steps
that they should take
as a result
of this comprehensive report
from this committee.
The biggest one that I'm seeing here
is that
this committee is recommending that
there be steps taken to enforce
the 14th Amendment section three.
This committee says,
of course, that
that part of the Constitution
says that anyone that incites
an insurrection
should be barred
from holding any future office.
So specifically,
it says
the committee believes that
those who took an oath
to protect
and defend
the Constitution on January 6th
should be barred,
disqualified and barred
from holding government office.
And if you read between the lines
there, of course,
they are pointing directly
at the former
President Trump,
who has already announced his candidacy
for 20, 24.
So that's a big step from this committee
saying that look
it's right there in the Constitution.
If you inciting an insurrection
you are barred from holding future
office.
Unclear
if that would actually be implemented,
but the committee is urging that.
And one other important thing
here, Laura, you know,
they're talking about
how law enforcement agencies
federal agencies, Secret
Service, really need to take a hard
look at violent extremism
because, of course,
that's part of what amplified
and sort of fed into this mob movement
that moved to the Capitol on January 6th,
breached the Capitol, stormed
inside, resulted in injuries,
even a few deaths
They're saying that law enforcement,
other agencies
need to take a big look at that.
And then, of course,
they're also saying,
oh, and here, Laura,
they're talking about
the electoral count act.
And of course, they want to codify that.
No vice president,
no other official can ever overthrow
the electoral count.
The electors that have been chosen
via individual states.
Of course,
that was something
that the former president was pushing
Vice President Mike Pence to do.
It's something
ultimately that
the vice president refused to do.
But the committee here
pointing out
that the House of Representatives
has passed
what's called the Presidential Election
Reform Act.
They are now urging the Senate to pass
that as well
so that it is codified
that the vice president
does not have any power in this process,
which, of course,
sort of
was one of the initial initial points
that the former president
tried to seize on
and urge the vice president
to overturn the election.
But a lot in here, Laura.
Most of it, though,
the narrative here
and really expounding upon everything
they've shown in testimony,
in the public testimony,
putting it in black and white,
and then in these appendices
detailing the recommendations
that they are making to many bodies
about what can be done now.
I want to bring in former U.S.
attorney Harry Litman.
Harry, I'm
so glad that you're with us tonight.
This is a very significant day.
We've been waiting for this
not just since Wednesday,
but really since, well,
probably January six when the committee
was actually impaneled
I'm wondering in terms of
you've seen recommendations,
there's about 11 of them
that goes beyond that initial
executive summary.
It includes things
like the Electoral Count Act.
That includes
accountability,
a deeper dove into violent extremism,
that includes
the national special security event
and the protocol that you do
to prevent this from happening.
But one in particular
that I'm really curious about,
your take as a former prosecutor
is this 14th Amendment Section three,
the one where frankly,
we recall the second impeachment
of the former president Donald Trump,
a focus was on the disqualification
of somebody from holding office.
Now we're in the future.
If the participated
or helped to incite
or give comfort
and aid to insurrectionists, for example.
Tell me about this particular section.
What stands out to you
about this recommendation?
The first
thing that stands
out is
the committee is actually going for it.
So Raskin made it clear in his remarks.
So did the Vice Chair, Cheney.
It's a bit of a constitutional puzzle.
And I've thought about this
and studied it a lot.
How exactly
you effectuate this provision
in the 14th Amendment that says
once you have sworn
an oath to the Constitution,
then committed insurrection
and you may not serve in the future?
It has to be.
It has to be the case
that it can be brought into effect.
And yet
there's some law out there
that suggests Congress has to vote it.
There's some law that
that suggests
just a judge or a jury could find it.
I think
the committee wasn't sure,
but they really want to make this play.
And you can see it,
the kind of grand compromise as to just
this large prompt from the body politic.
So the big thing is they're going for it
and they're remember that
just just this week.
40 Republican
40 Democrats
in the House of Representatives
have done a motion to try to effectuate
just this.
Raskin is clearly the author of it.
He's the constitutional law professor.
It must be able to be done.
But how exactly is a mystery?
And they want to get it right
because the risk is
you'd go through all the steps
So that's something that really
jumped out at me, jumped out
even on Monday.
It's a really important point because
the idea of the proof
and the going for it,
given the fact that I mean,
on the one hand, Harry, it's great news.
It's not a whole lot of precedent
on a case like this. Right.
You don't want there to be volumes
about case
law that actually talks
about people who were aiding and abetting
and or giving aid and comfort
or actually fighting insurrection
against our government.
But because of that, in this case,
law and common law system
that we're in,
when we look at former cases
and we decide how to go forward
based on the former
holdings of the court,
it is a difficult thing to address.
But in their criminal referrals,
you remember
there was language
about the incitement statute.
They were trying to articulate
the language tracks.
In some respects, the same outcome.
Was that a way to try to nudge the DOJ
to look into a statute
that would do this very thing?
It was politically unavailable
to them, to the impeachment
I think
100%, although they also want to do it
on their own.
It's sparse
precedent there,
but the last time it was done,
it was by vote of Congress.
There is a 19th century precedent
that says it has to be vote by Congress.
They want to do it both ways.
They want to do belt and suspenders.
And there's all kinds
of different reasons why.
It's tricky, I think, to remember
this is a qualification.
There are only three or four
in the Constitution.
You have to be 35 years old.
You can't be foreign born
and you may not have done this.
Now, the Supreme Court has made it clear
you can't add to those qualifications.
But if you're doing that insurrection,
that's what
tracks that the 14th Amendment
and it's a hard charge law.
As you know.
It's got a checkered history.
We have Trump saying be peaceful.
There's no real agreement here.
They have to go by aiding and abetting.
That's why,
though, I believe it
showed up in this final list before that.
And it was the surprise
entry of the four.
We're really going to see in
subsequent weeks how this plays out.
I also want to address this
because, you know,
you and
I have had these conversations
over the better
part of
six years at this point
about the notion of subpoena power
and what would it
what it takes as prosecutor
when you give somebody a subpoena.
It's not like an invitation
to a Tea Party. You can sort of decline.
You're supposed to show up.
But then in recent years,
the subpoenas
that have been issued by Congress,
they've had
their noses have been thumbed at Congress
for a variety of reasons.
One other recommendations
in this very report
deals with the House's civil
subpoena enforcement authority.
And they say the current authority
on how to enforce their own subpoenas
through civil litigation is unclear.
This is a really interesting
take because they probably anticipate
the fact that there has been
and the Supreme Court then bets it down.
about people no longer
seeing the gravitas
that ought to be attached
to a congressional subpoena.
It's a great point.
And really, it's
the same with it's gotten comedy.
Well, you can ignore
congressional says the only reason
the only reason is Congress's
only last two years.
And then once they expire, a subpoena
expired, while Trump in particular
and before said go,
it was always either
honored or negotiated
But they develop
this strategy
of just playing it out until Congress.
So you're right,
it is one of the big recommendations.
Therefore, appendices at the end,
you've dealt with almost all of them.
There's also foreign corruption
and the big lie, the graft, as it were,
where Trump
raised all this money
and used it for bad purposes.
But that's up about half of what here.
And the other half.
There are little snippets
that they didn't present to us.
They did a very good job
did the committee of really
putting their best foot forward.
But now there was a whole bunch
that we didn't see
because it wasn't
in the front of the hearings.
But that really does fill in the details.
Roger Stone, for example,
or the the way the Proud Boys took Trump.
It will be wild as a summons
to come to D.C.
the way he knew about the big lie.
Those little savings are done.
Other than that, though,
I think the 14th Amendment thing
you've just mentioned, this huge
and these series of recommendations
in the appendices.